rés ce qui me rappelle quand même à
combien les les sondeurs se trompe dans
la politique américaine comme dans la
nôtre mais évidemment est dans une
situation très inquiétante soit trump
gagne de justesse et on repart pour
quatre ans d'imprévisibilité
d'instabilité 10 yona sionisme américain
par rapport à tout ce qui est cadre de
règles multilatérales fracturation
division de la société américaine et
puis évidemment si joe biden gagne une
situation tendue pour humblement des
contestations pendant pendant quelques
jours
je veux croire que même s'il gagne de
justesse on sera dans la situation où
souvenez-vous george w bush avait gagné
de justesse de manière quasiment très
contestable avec la floride
mais finalement les institutions aux
états unis sont fortes et ce à son
élection n'avait plus été contestée
finalement la seule question sibide on
gagne c'est est-ce que donald trump va
prendre un moment donné
le costume la stature d'un président des
états unis et se retirer avec
responsabilité et lucidité
c'est ce qu'elle avait finalement fait
al gore en 2000 ce que vous venez
d'évoquer le lot de questions qui ont
ramé qui se pose c'est que si les
résultats les résultats sont très très
serré est-ce qu'on peut on peut nous
prépare redouter qu'un joe biden élu
avec une toute petite marge n'est pas
les coudées franches pour mener la
politique qu'il a présentée pendant sa
campagne notamment en matière de 2,2
climat ce qui est évident c'est que
les buy donne gagnera quand même le vote
populaire comme clinton y avait gagné il
ya quatre ans c'est à dire qu' on ne
peut pas contester qu'il y ait une
majorité des lectrices et des lecteurs
américains qui auront voté pour le
président élu là où vous avez raison
c'est que sans vague bleue la couleur
qui représente les démocrates
il est très peu probable que le sénat
bascule et que lier une majorité
qualifiée au congrès américain pour
faire passer des lois extrêmement forte
en revanche il est évident que vous
l'avez dit sur la question du climat sur
la question sociale parce que le
programme de byden est aussi un
programme social ça va être difficile
il a nous savons des outils notamment l'
agence de protection de l'environnement
qui lui permet sinon d'agir du avec le
législatif au moins d'agir avec le
réglementaire mais il est évident qu'il
va falloir que les états unis qui
aujourd'hui sorte de l'accord de paris
puisque il faut quatre ans pour sortir
de l'accord de paris des états unis qui
sortent aujourd'hui de l'accord de paris
il faut qu'ils reviennent il faut que
byron s'appuie sur les états fédérés
s'appuie sur les entreprises s'appuient
sur les villes qui malgré trump ont
continué d'agir et quoi qu'il en soit si
c'est le dernier point sur cette
élection
ça n'enlève rien à l'urgence que
l'europe s'organise mieux que l'europe
approfondissez politique économique
sociale évidemment environnementale de
défense parce que même si byden remplace
trump à la tête des états unis on a de
toute façon besoin d'une europe forte
une europe capable d'agir dans son
voisinage on voit à quel point de la
libye à la turquie notre voisinage est
déstabilisé est source de conflits
potentiels et donc de toute façon
il faudra un post honnête non notamment
puisque vous parlez d'une rapporte
notamment sur la question du commerce du
protectionnisme c'est important ça dans
les relations entre l'union européenne
et les etats-unis est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que l'élection de joe biden va
changer les choses ou est-ce que de
toute façon ça restera l'amérique
d'abord face à une europe qui doit se
renforcer et s'organiser ici un point
positif qu'il faut retirer de la période
de trump c'est qu'il a démontré que ce
que nous disions d'ailleurs tous par
ailleurs l'économie c'est de la
politique l'économie c'est la
souveraineté alors il l'a fait pour le
pire pour le pire des protectionnismes
mais il est évident que l'europe de
toute façon doit s'armer bien davantage
dans le commerce international il est
évident qu'avec d'haydn il y aura je
pense le retour des états unis à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce que
les conflits avec l'europe de toute
façon devrait être moins dur mais ça
sert question doit devenir plus
protectionniste aller trop naïve à
l'heure actuelle sur ces questions pour
vous elle doit davantage défendre ses
intérêts qui sont des intérêts globaux
moi je défend un protectionnisme vert
par exemple je suis responsable pour le
parlement européen de la taxe carbone
aux frontières
c'est un enjeu essentiel à la fois pour
que notre agenda climatique soit
beaucoup plus fort en europe mais que ça
mette pas en danger nos entreprises qui
pourraient être victimes d'une
concurrence déloyale venant d'autres
pays comme la chine ou les états unis
cissé trump donc de la même façon on a
trop souvent abandonné nos classes
populaires nous nos ouvriers pour aller
exploiter ce du sud et de l'est
défendent l'idée que les produits qui
entrent sur le marché européen doivent
être des produits qui dans leur pays
respecte la liberté syndicale lutte
contre le travail forcé parce que sinon
si vous voulez si on se laisse envahir
par huawei
si on laisse les chinois par exemple
comme les russes racheter une partie de
nos infrastructures vitales dans
l'énergie
dans les transports nous ne pourrons
plus défendre les valeurs de l'union
européenne que ce soit à hong kong
évidemment que ce soit pour les ouigours
ou que pour ce soit la démocratie en
europe et en russie
donc l'enjeu pour l'europe c'est
d'affirmer à la fois de la résilience
produire davantage ce qui est
indispensable pour nous on l'a vu sur
les médicaments c'est d'affirmer une
souveraineté économique avec un
programme de relocalisation de
réindustrialisation et c'est vrai que
pour faire le lien avec le premier sujet
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique est une incroyable
opportunité pour faire de l'innovation
bas carbone pour pour innover dans nos
entreprises pour innover dans nos
transports pour innover dans toutes nos
méthodes de production justement pour
créer de l'emploi y compris à l'échelle
des territoires qui en ont terriblement
besoin est l'autre sujet sur lequel on
attend l'union européenne yannick jadot
c'est la lutte contre le terrorisme la
france et l'autriche frappé ces derniers
jours l'état islamique a d'ailleurs
revendiqué hier soir l'attak de vienne
est ce que au delà des condamnations
unanimes en europe
il manque une réponse forte une réponse
coordonnée sur ce sujet on a vu
malheureusement que le soutien la france
par rapport aux attentats de conflent et
l'est de nice n'ont pas toujours été à
la hauteur de ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
il y avait une sorte de petite musique
comme quoi finalement la liberté
d'expression à la française
il y en avait un peu assez ce qu'on voit
c'est que le sujet ne se sont pas des
caricatures ce qui est blasphématoire
pour l'islamisme radical comme pour les
dirigeants du monde qui ont appelé au
boycott des produits français
quelle indignité au moment où nous
subissions des attentats ce qui est
blasphématoire
c'est la liberté d'expression c'est la
démocratie ce sont les valeurs que nous
défendons c'est la liberté de conscience
et y compris le droit à la caricature et
donc on a besoin d'une europe qui est
vous savez divisés sur l'état de droit
avec des problèmes avec la pologne avec
la hongrie notamment
on a besoin d'une europe qui affirme à
la fois une détermination absolue dans
la lutte contre l'islamisme radical et
le terrorisme
des outils ont été créés et quand même
ces dernières années qui nous permettent
de renforcer la coopération des services
de renseignement elle n'est pas parfaite
mais on a beaucoup progressé là-dessus
mais il nous faut si on veut marcher sur
deux jambes tenir la promesse
républicaine parce que partout en europe
là où l'islamisme radical prolifèrent
c'est que souvent l'état la puissance
publique s'est retirée que e on a de la
ghettoïsation on a des discriminations
territoriales économiques sociales
ethniques religieuses on a du racisme on
à l'explosion de la pauvreté et si nous
en france comme en europe
on ne tient pas la promesse républicaine
on voit la pauvreté qui va toucher 10
millions donc aux patriots en france un
jeune sur cinq
si on ne retient pas notre promesse
républicaine en agissant contre la
pauvreté en mettant en oeuvre le plan
borloo en restaurant 300000 emplois
aidés notamment dans les quartiers pour
que les associations laïques ne soit pas
concurrencés par des associations
islamistes pour faire du social et la
solidarité
si on ne recrée pas là la cohésion
ceci à la cohésion nationale alors on
aura beaucoup de difficultés de toute
façon à lutter contre l'islamisme
radical yannick jadot voudrais parler d'
outils vous venez de dire que les outils
qui existent et au niveau européen ont
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
quels sont-ils et qu'est ce qui manque
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait mettre en place pour
notamment sur le sur le volet sécurité
et lutte coordonnée contre le contre le
terrorisme en europe
je les dis la coopération des services
de renseignement a beaucoup progressé
mais ça reste une grande difficulté il
ya des pays qui jouent pas le jeu
les conneries parce que c'est difficile
c'est difficile pour un service de
renseignement finalement coopéré avec
ses voisins c'est aussi
donner ses sources c'est aussi des
cultures c'est pas forcément un blocage
politique
ce sont des cultures différentes mais ça
a énormément progressé ce qui me paraît
important aujourd'hui c'est la démarche
a été entreprise par thierry breton en
tant que commissaire sur le numérique
c'est le digital services act la loi sur
les services numériques qui nous
permettra parce que le grand combat sur
le terrorisme des sur l'islamisme
radical aujourd'hui il est évidemment
sur les financements sur la formation et
je les dis sur la promesse républicaine
mais il est sur les réseaux est ce que
veut faire le commissaire breton que je
soutiens que nous allons soutenir en
tant que député vert c'est de rendre
davd d'ancrer la responsabilité légale
des plateformes à l'échelle européenne
c'est évidemment de bien davantage
contrôler la question des algorithmes la
question de l'identification des comptes
et puis la capacité à sanctionner
immédiatement les plateformes
quand elles sont permissive laxiste
vis-à-vis des messages qui se diffuse
sur les réseaux mais il faut dire que
s'il faut un réarmement juridique sur la
question des réseaux il faut aussi un
réarmement idéologique plus de 90% des
messages sur les réseaux sociaux autour
de l'islam sont des messages islamistes
il faut absolument créer toutes les
conditions soutenir tous les toutes les
associations et je vois de plus en plus
l'ailé
les musulmanes et les musulmans se
saisir de cette responsabilité d'aller
combattre les messages pervers les
messages fondamentalistes sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est essentiel ce combat idéologique
autres
luigi di maio qui est le chef de la
diplomatie italienne lui il propose
l'idée d'une loi antiterroriste commune
à l'union européenne à l'image du
patriot act américain le patriot act
américain ça restera quand même un
certain nombre de libertés fondamentales
est ce que c'est une idée que vous
soutenez l'idée de luigi du maillot non
est-ce qu'il faut des règles européennes
communes oui parce que je suis
profondément européen et sur cette
menace comme sur les autres on a besoin
d'europe mais il faut se souvenir de ce
que c'est que le patriot act qui avait
été lancée par george w bush
c'est aussi dans la ligne du patriote du
patriot act qu'on a fait guantanamo
s'est créé des zones permanente de non
droit et ça c'est inacceptable
ça serait ça serait dire finalement que
les terroristes ont gagné à partir du
moment où on ne respecte plus l'état
droit à partir du moment où on ne
respecte plus les libertés
on les enfreint en permanence on donne
un pouvoir extraordinaire à ce patriot
act contre les libertés
moi je suis pour l'efficacité je serai
je suis intraitable
que ce soit sur le terrorisme ou sur
l'islamisme radical
mais on ne peut pas faire ce cadeau aux
terroristes qui est de sortir
complètement du droit pour les combattre
souvenons nous de la tâche que
représente guantanamo dans le droit
américain
il n'a apporté aucune réponse contre le
terrorisme au contraire il a finalement
cristalliser le lol la mobilisation
terroristes et au niveau national on
fait comment j'imagine que vous avez vu
vous avez suivi la proposition de loi
fort vert sur la sécurité globale qui
sera qui va être examinée par par
l'assemblée en commission cette dès
cette semaine
est-ce que les propositions qui sont qui
sont faites vous conviennent et
notamment l'idée de donner plus de
pouvoir aux polices municipales
est-ce que c'est compatible avec avec
tous cas tout ce qu ont professé les
verts en la matière ces dernières années
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
les verts dirige un certain nombre de
villes et dans ces villes
nous avons renforcé les polices
municipales et comme souvent face à le
retrait de la police nationale nous
avons demandé comme à bordeaux qu'il y
ait de nouveau un bataillon de crs pour
maintenir l'ordre
la sécurité c'est une des priorités de
nos compatriotes
évidemment il faut renforcer la sécurité
est-ce qu'il faut armer ces polices
municipales être qu'il faut renforcer la
vidéoprotection dans les villes dirigées
par les écologistes ou utiliser les
drones par exemple pour la pour la
surveillance de proposer dans la loi qui
est proposé c'est essentiellement une
loi qui tourne autour du maintien de
l'ordre notamment dans les
manifestations et là malheureusement on
a vu que ces dernières années il y avait
une rupture dans la tradition
républicaine du maintien de l'ordre ou
la politique imposée aux policiers aux
forces de sécurité et souvent confrontés
à des situations inextricables de
violence cette logique là avaient
conduit à des escalades qui sont
insupportables et pour les manifestants
et pour les policiers
donc il faut là pour le coup s'inspirer
de ce qui se passe en europe
toutes les techniques aujourd'hui de
maintien de l'ordre qui sont des
techniques de désescalade qui sont des
techniques pour s'assurer que la
manifestation puisse se dérouler dans
les meilleures conditions
y compris pour exfiltrer des semeurs de
troubles qui viennent comme les black
blocks pourrir les manifestations et
générer de la violence
il faut s'inspirer de ça c'est pour les
manifestations c'est pour les
manifestations yannick jadot pour la
sécurité du quotidien est ce qu'on armes
la police une comptable c'est que la
vidéo ce que les sentiers en train de
faire vous avez raison ce qui est ce qui
est essentiel aujourd'hui c'est de
garantir la sécurité et la tranquillité
et la protection de nos concitoyens ce
que sont en train de faire les maires
est ce que revendique depuis longtemps à
l'échelle nationale c'est
de recréer à l'échelle des quartiers une
articulation beaucoup plus fort entre
une police de proximité avec des
magistrats avec des animateurs sociaux
autour des habitantes et des habitants
pour identifier à l'échelle de chaque
immeuble
les problèmes de sécurité et se donner
les moyens de les traiter
vous savez moi j'ai proposé que à
l'image de ce qui avait été fait sous
lionel jospin c'est la conférence de
viltain tu savais lancez le la police de
proximité
j'ai proposé qu'il y ait une conférence
du respect et de la confiance entre la
police et la population et la société
parce qu'il va nous falloir un moment
donné redonner du sens aux métiers de
policiers ou de gendarmes eux-mêmes mais
toujours pas certaines difficultés en
service sont précarisés il va falloir
redonner du sens à leur métier et
surtout il va falloir une grande loi de
programmation qui leur donne les moyens
d'exercer leurs missions
on a vu comment sarkozy et la droite qui
revendique aujourd'hui le le le
la médaille d'or de la sécurité on a vu
comment ils ont réduit de 13 mille
postes dans la lah les forces de l'ordre
policiers gendarmes ils ont déstabilisé
le renseignement de terrain nous désarme
en face à l'islamisme radical au
terrorisme en revanche ils ont armé les
terroristes du sel en faisant la guerre
de manière outrancière en libye donc
c'est tout ça qu'il faut changer
remettre de la présence humaine
redonnait des moyens à la police pour
qu'elle tienne les missions qui lui sont
donnés sortir d'une politique du chiffre
totalement absurde qui détourne la
police de ces vraies missions de
protection yannick jadot on va parler de
la crise sanitaire ya un nouveau conseil
de défense qu'a lieu ce matin jean luc
mélenchon lui fustige ce conseil de
défense il dit que c'est un comité
secret autour d' emmanuel macron pour se
protéger judiciairement et mettre tout
le monde à l'abri est ce que vous
partagez son avis
on est face à une crise absolument
dramatique
il faut avoir conscience que il ya une
inquiétude immense de la part des
personnels de santé dans cette deuxième
vague et que nous devons tous et toutes
être responsable dans le moment moi j'ai
appelé depuis des mois le président de
la république a organisé un conseil de
sécurité sanitaire avec évidemment les
ministres les experts le conseil
scientifique mais aussi les forces
politiques les forces vives du pays
syndicats patronat associations qui
interviennent dans dans la séquence
sanitaire sociale pour qu'il y ait pas
ce que l'on sait que c'est un certain ce
ce virus on sait qu'il reste mystérieux
il faut qu'on crée une forme de
consensus
des forces politiques des élus autour
des mesures qui doivent être prises moi
j'appelle les françaises et les français
à respecter les règles y compris et
presque d'autant plus que le
gouvernement a parfois failli que ce
soit sur la question des masques ça
c'était la première vague sur la
question des tests comme il a failli à
réarmer nos services de réanimation mais
d'une certaine façon c'est si ces couacs
de communication qui crée la défiance y
compris vis-à-vis de la règle édictée
j'appelle chacune et chacun à respecter
et j'appelle le président de la
république a créé
plutôt que de décider seul dans son
bureau avec quelques conseillers
on a vu l'aberration de la fermeture des
librairies et des commerces de proximité
je l'appelle à travailler avec les
forces vives de ce pays c'est comme ça
qu'on retrouvera un peu de confiance
et puis c'est comme ça parce que c'est
essentiel à mon avis aujourd'hui pour
les françaises et les français
il nous faut nous redonner un horizon à
deux ans du point de vue sanitaire comme
du point de vue économique et social
on ne peut pas multiplier les mesures
d'urgence qui sont parfois incohérentes
les unes avec les autres et on ne peut
pas avoir un gouvernement qui sont
contredits de runner sur les mesures
d'urgence
mettre en place vous appelez à respecter
les règles est ce que vous estimez que
le confinement qui nous est prêt je
respecte moi je suis qu'à contacter je
suis chez moi est ce que est ce qu est
ce que vous estimez que le confinement
qui est qui et ce deuxième confinement
est trop light entre guillemets est ce
que vous seriez favorable à de nouvelles
mesures plus dures on parlait on a parlé
hier de de la réinstauration de
couvre-feu dans les grandes villes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez très bien
je les dis la situation est absolument
dramatique
et nous devons y compris
particulièrement les élus être
responsable et appelé au respect des
règles
le problème c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'est une règle qui est prise on ne
sait pas exactement quelle est la
rationalité sanitaire économique social
qui lie à derrière donc c'est très
difficile et puis on a l'impression
desquesnes règle qui est posé on pense
déjà la règle suivante je les dis moi
j'appelle le président de la république
à installer dans la durée parce que
cette situation va durer
un conseil de sécurité sanitaire avec
les forces politiques avec les forces
vives du pays
il n'y a qu'en semble qu'on se donnera
les moyens de combattre et fit et
efficacement ce virus il n'y a qu'en
semble qu'on arrivera à se donner une
perspective est un peu d'espoir la
confusion installés par le gouvernement
et par le président de la république
autour des politiques de santé publique
nhs est vraiment pas à la mobilisation
citoyenne
ce sera le mot de la femme
[Musique]